breaking news right now we continue to
follow new developments in the murder
case of review journal investigative
reporter jeff gearman right now metro
police are searching the home of clark
county public administrator rob talas in
connection to that crime 8 news now is
vanessa murphy live at the search at
charleston and wallapy vanessa still a
very active scene there
that's right heather and we just saw
clark county sheriff joe lombardo leave
the scene after speaking with
investigators by the home that is being
searched i'll step out of the way so you
can see this is an active investigation
as you mentioned sources tell me robert
tellis is with investigators right now
as they work to figure out if he's
connected to the murder of long-time
investigative journalist jeff gearman
here at the home of telus again an
active scene and a couple of things to
note here jeff gehrman had done several
stories in the review journal on public
administrator robert tellis and the
problems within his office telus then
lost the democratic primary yesterday we
showed you video of a vehicle police
were looking for the suspect vehicle
this gmc yukon our photojournalist shop
video of that vehicle or a vehicle just
like that one excuse me here earlier at
the home of telus metro police also
released video of the suspect and you
can see this person appears to be in
disguise wide brim hat and construction
type clothing metro police say the
suspect had been casing the area prior
to the crime gearman was found stabbed
to death outside his northwest valley
home saturday morning police say he was
killed friday morning now back here live
police tell me they will be here for at
least another few hours a lot of moving
parts here again robert tell us
currently with investigators as they
work to figure out if he is connected to
this journalist's murder and we just saw
clark county sheriff joe lombardo here
at the scene reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now